there's 12 signs that your gallbladder
is in trouble but the most common sign
over 80 of the time is a symptom called
asymptomatic which means no symptoms the
great majority of time people do not
have any clue that they have a
gallbladder problem however even though
there's no major symptoms there are all
sorts of clues that I'm going to cover
that will tell you what's going on with
the gallbladder the gallbladder is a
very very important organ okay it's not
an extra organ that we don't need it's a
storage place for bile so it can
concentrate so every time you eat
the gallbladder contracts and then that
bile is secreted into the small
intestines and it helps extract certain
fats like fat soluble vitamins and
nutrients it helps you break down fat
but that's just the tip of the iceberg
there's many other things that it does
number one it's antibacterial so in
other words it keeps the bacteria out of
the small intestine to prevent this
overgrowth or fermentation that can
occur and it's very common with people
especially if they
you know eat fiber or a big salad and
they feel bloated they could have
something called sibo small intestinal
bacterial overgrowth and and that's
probably because they don't have enough
bile to act as a kind of a detergent
um antimicrobial to flush that out and
then what happens is this bile goes all
the way down this tube which is quite
long and then it gets reabsorbed right
before the large intestine and it
actually gets reabsorbed 18 times so
your body is very efficient in a
recycles bile because it's very very
important but if this bile is not the
right
texture or the right thickness let's say
it's too thick becomes sludge if it
becomes too concentrated you get
gallstones and then you can start
plugging up the little tubes they're
called bile ducts and then everything
kind of backs up so I'm going to go
through these signs most of them are a
bile deficiency symptom because there's
a blockage of some sort but there's one
that is a bile excess especially if you
had your gallbladder removed so just to
let you know a stone a gallstone is a
super concentrated cholesterol Stone
normally okay and that stone occurs
because we have a lot of concentrated
cholesterol and and this is the most
important thing to know you don't have
enough bile to keep it flowing or to
keep it thin so this bile helps break
down cholesterol so really a gallstone
or bio sludge is a deficiency of bile
for some reason and I'll get into the
the reasons so anyway this sludge backs
up or plugs something up or obstructs
something and because these little tubes
can distend or stretch so they have
stretch receptors and when they stretch
too much it can create something called
visceral pain which can feel like a deep
burning or gnawing or tightness
underneath the right rib cage it can
also definitely make you feel nauseated
now because there's a nerve that's
connected to your diaphragm that goes up
to the right side and the left side but
we're going to focus on the right side
if there's pressure on that gallbladder
there's going to be pressure underneath
your diaphragm and on something called
the phrenic nerve and that's going to
refer pain right here okay right in this
area right through in here and it can
literally create a tightness to the
point where it can pull these vertebra
out of place and pinch the nerve and
actually cause pain down the right side
I've seen it so many times in practice
it can also back up the liver and cause
the liver to kind of get congested and
cause pain in the back part between your
scapula and the spine and the rhomboid
muscle right back over here and I've had
that for probably 12 years I didn't know
what it was I would get it adjusted
because I was a chiropractor probably
had
I don't know maybe
5 000 adjustments and it would give me
some relief and then it would just keep
coming back over and over and over so
anytime like you go to a chiropractor
and you get treated and you have to keep
going and keep going spec there could be
something else behind it like referred
pain usually related to something you're
eating or some digestive issue now you
can also have a a blockage as it crosses
over into the pancreatic duct and cause
pain on the left side too so whether
it's the left side or the right side
um suspect gallbladder or bile duct
sludge and there's another really good
uh clue to know that you don't have
enough bile and that would be the color
of your stool normally it should be
Brown
when you lose bile it's going to become
more light like a pale color or even a
gray color and usually your stool will
float because you're not digesting the
fat so then the fat is going to just
accumulate undigested and make your
stool flow that's probably one of the
best clues that you don't have enough
bile that you might not feel but you can
observe that and then as a remedy for
that you just want to take a more
purified bile salts to give your body
more bile so then you can actually start
digesting fats another common symptom
would be itchiness it could be anywhere
in the body and many times it's at night
for some reason now the next one is
different this one is too much bile
which normally happens after you have
the gallbladder removed and then now we
don't have anywhere to control it so now
they're just constant trickle and
sometimes it can actually be too much
and so that symptom would would be
diarrhea
watery stools and no control over your
bowel movements and with that problem
you're gonna have to go to the doctor
and they're going to give you a certain
medication to slow down this bile
production another sign that you if a
gallbladder problem is that your urine
is dark yellow or it could even be a
brown type coloring because part of your
bile is a waste product of your red
blood cells and so it can cause a
different color of the urine and stool
if there's a stone involved and it's
backing up the bile into the liver and
out through the skin you can develop
jaundice so that's where your skin is
yellow and the whites of your eyes are
yellow as well another symptom would be
vomiting I mean just think about if you
have a blockage in your bile ducts and
it's backing up into the liver you're
gonna have a sick stomach and because
excess bile causes diarrhea a deficiency
of biome will cause constipation because
there's no lubrication there but I think
we should talk about what can cause the
gallbladder to be in trouble
interestingly when people have a
gallbladder they're told to
not consume fats okay going a low-fat
diet which is not the right answer
because what triggers the contraction
and release of bile is fat and protein
so when someone goes on a low-fat diet
okay they're at risk for developing
gallstones and so if you have gallstones
taking a little more fat is not a bad
thing it's going to increase more
production of bile another common thing
that can cause this problem is um
birth control pills or the spike in
estrogen from being pregnant or any type
of estrogen therapy another thing would
be high levels of cortisol that could be
from stress or it could be from the drug
prednisone insulin is another cause if
you are on a high carb diet and you have
high levels of insulin you're more
susceptible to having gallstones and
this is why a lot of diabetics who are
basically probably doing too many carbs
have more problems with gallstones and
also certain type of medication that
remove or block acid from the stomach
like ppis can put you at risk for having
gallstones probably because that
hydrochloric acid is another trigger for
the release of bile because as that
protein and fat is going into the
stomach it's going to tell the liver to
let's go ahead and make sure we have
enough bile that's stored in the
gallbladder to be able to digest this
fatty piece of meat so if you're
removing the acid from the stomach you
might not get the signals and so in some
people the way to actually get the bile
back is to fix the stomach add more
hydrochloric acid in the form of betaine
hydrochloride so it's important to have
a full knowledge of the gallbladder and
all the potential causes so you could
you know find out what your causes and
then Taylor make it to what caused your
actual problem because as you can see
there's a wide range of things that can
cause a problem with this now this is an
interesting relationship between
melatonin and bile people that have low
melatonin they have enhanced cholesterol
turning into a stone now in Chinese
medicine they use bile salts to help
reduce fever bile salts can also be used
as an anti-inflammatory bowel cells can
help you get more absorption from the
fat cyber vitamins vitamin A d e in K
and bile cells can also help prevent the
excessive growth of microbes to keep the
microbes in check what do you do if you
have some of these problems
I would recommend to take some form of
purified bile salt okay right after the
meal I'd probably take one or two and
then on an empty stomach I would take
something else called Tut cup tadka is a
very specialized type of biosol that
works better
on an empty stomach because it starts to
thin the bile and it's really good for a
lot of problems it especially that
sludge and the problem is if you took it
with a meal then it's going to work more
on the the dietary food and not what's
happening inside your liver and your
body which is usually either a stone or
sludge now fiber like I'm talking about
salads
can also help uh with this condition as
well because it's really good for the
liver and it does help to balance out
the fiber as well as the cholesterol
potential for developing into a stone
and lastly don't go on a low-fat diet I
already mentioned fat and protein
increasing the production of bile but I
didn't mention this ketones which are a
byproduct of fat can also help contract
that gallbladder so ketones can help
increase the production of bile as well
as the gallbladder Contracting to
release the bile so now that you have
this information there's other causes of
bloating other than the gallbladder
being an issue and if you haven't seen
this video I think you'll be quite
interested